[音楽]
今日は皆さんに本当にやりたいことを見つけるための3つのポイントをお伝えします
人は小さい頃は大きくなったら何になりたいってよく聞かれますが
一旦大人になると自分が本当は何がやりたいのかって考える機会が急に少なくなると
思います
目の前にはやらなきゃいけないことがたくさんあってそれをやっているとあっという間
に一日が終わりますよね
それで1週間1カ月1年です指が冷えた過ぎ去っちゃうんです
ではその身の前にたくさんあるやらなきゃいけない事ってどこから来るのか一緒に考え
てみましょう
例えばいい会社に就職しないといけないん
家事と
仕事はきちんと両立しないといけない
そういったやらなきゃいけない事っていうのは
すべきことっていうのは自分の家から思い出てくるものではなくて世間の流れであると
か
周りからの期待とか外から来るものですよねそういった外から来るしバレっていうのが
あるんです
それを自分の希望だと思って頑張り続けてしまうことがあるんです
こういう風に自分の願いと周りからの縛りを混同したまま頑張り続けているとだんだん
心が疲れていくんです
本当にやりたいことを見つけるための1つ目のポイントは
外から来た縛りに気づくことなんです
世間の流れとか周りからの評価とかそういったことからくるしばれに気がついたら
ちょっと一歩離れて見て自分自身を見つめてみてほしいんです
そうすると縛りの中にある本当の想い
自由な希望そういったものが見えてくるかもしれません
2つ目のポイントは自分自身がだんだん変化しているっていう事に気づくことなんです
以前決めたゴールに向かってがんばっているうちにいつのまにかそのゴールに魅力を
感じなくなることがあるんです
置かれている環境とか経験が積み重ねることによって人の価値観ってだんだん変わって
いくんです
だからゴールは変わっていいんです
試しに自分が少し変化しているかなーって気ずき付いてみるのもいいです
以前欲しかったもの今欲しいかどうか
以前読んでた本を
今読みたいかどうか
人間関係なども徐々に変わってきているんじゃないでしょうか
3つ目のポイントですけど
自分自身を今ここにあるということを築くことなんです
どういうことかと言いますと過去にあった出来事ずっと考えていたり
未来のことを不安に思ってとらわれていると今ここ
今の自分が見えなくなりますよね
今自分が何を思ってどう感じているのかっていうのを客ん的に見てみることなんです
例えば今ちょっと不安でもやもやしているとき
頭の中で私は今不安に思っている
文章化してみるのも一つの良い方法ですそうすると百貫的に自分の思いというのも
見つめることができます
私は普段病院で診療したりしてるんですけど
ストレスをいっぱい抱えているのにそれに気づかないで頑張り続けて体調ぷとしてから
外来に来られる方がたくさんいらっしゃいます
では私自身はどうだったかというと
今まで仕事と子育てで一生懸命頑張ってきました
仕事と子育てちゃってしながら目標に向かって走り続けてきたんですね
でも実際は周りからの評価ばかり気にして自分が変化しているっていう事には気付か
ないで
そして過去や未来のことばっかり考えていました
私が医者になろうと思ったのは中学校の頃です
母が老人ホームで働いてたんです
父は医者をしていました
高齢者と触れ合う機会が多い中で法令者の医療や福祉に関わる仕事がしたいって思った
んです
それで医者になって
法令者にを医療器を学ぼうと思って神経内科という道に進みました
ら神経内科って私にとってはとっても難しかったんです
周りのドクターみたいにうまくできませんでした
それで毎日診療研究頑張っているうちに
私の目標は高齢者の医療福祉がしたかったのに
神経内科の道を究めることにいつのまにか変わってたんです
アメリカで2年研究生活もしました
その時は論文をたくさんかいで成果を残そうと思って頑張ってました
なかなか成果が出なかったんです1年経ってもたっても一つも論文が書けませんでした
そうしているうちに過去の失敗を何度も思い返したり
これからどうなるんだろうて先のことを考え出したりして働けなくなってきたんです
火がついたら
私は鬱状態になってました
とてもつらかったです
今考えれば
周りからの評価を気にしてええかを出さなければと思っていただけで自分は研究をし
たいからアメリカに行こうって思ったわけじゃなかったんですね
ちょっと贅沢な話ですが
日本に帰ってから結婚したんですがその時もまだ自分は神経内科の道を究めるんだと
いう気持ちで頑張り続ける日が続きます
私には今子供が2人いて年子なんです
5歳と6歳でとっても可愛いんですけど
1人目は前に
出産する前に資格を取らなくてはと思いました
それで真剣ないパの専門医の資格を取ろうと思ったんです
この試験があるのが東京でしかまさに臨月の時で撮ったんですね
でもこれは絶対取らなきゃいけないと思ってたので周りの反対を押し切っていきました
資金等ってもともとが8ヶ月になって筆記しました
その後また民心をして二人目を授かった時
温度はま単位学博士の博士棒を取っておかなくてはと思ったんですね
ここまでやらないと認められないっていうなんか強迫観念のようなものでその時も奮闘
しました
そしてまた子どもが8ヶ月で復旧したんで
ん
復旧をした方は心身共に疲れ切ってました
保育園に預けて病院にまでの運転する間ほんと後6分なんですけどその短い間だけが1
人きりになれる唯一の時間だったんです
なぜ誰か涙がポロポロこぼれるんですね
自分は
頑張っているようだけれども働こう母さんってみんなこのぐらい頑張ってるんじゃない
かと思って
岩根を履いたらいけないと思っていました
そんな私が
自分のことを見つめ直そうって思ったのが2年前です
ある時ふと10年後の自分を思い浮かべたんです
このままずっと働いていて10年後って私幸せだろうかって思ったんです
子供とか家族とか社会に貢献でているだろうかと考えた時に何か疑問がわいてきました
今のままの生活をしていたら
幸せになれないような気分になってきたんですねそこで
1日少しの愛でも間でも自分を見つめる時間を取ろうと思ったんです
朝早く起きて子どもたちが寝静まっている時間
本当にチョップの時間なんですけど本を読んだり
自分の思いを吐き出したりすることをやってみました
例えば私の強みて何私がワクワクすることで波
逆に不安に思っていることって何だろういろんな角度から見つめて言ったんですそう
すると私が本当に求めているものがだんだん見えてきました
私が本当に求めているもの
やりたいことっていうのは
人が自分らしく生涯を全うできる社会をつくることがあったんです
ちょっと相談に聞こえますけど具体的に言うと
病気を治すのではなくて表記にならないように
するためにはどうしたらいいかを伝えられる石になりたいって思ったんです
神経内科を極めるということは私にとってとっても大切な要素になったんですがそれは
最終的な目標ではなかったんですね
今日ですね私な私が皆さんにお伝えしたいと思うことは
3つにあると言いました周りからの縛りに気づくこと
自分が世間体とかそういったもので調べられているということに気が付いたら少し離れ
て縛りの中の自分を見つめることです
そして2つ目が自分が変化しているということに気付くこと
過去の自分に縛られているっていう事に気がついたら今の自分
ちょっと変わってしまったけれども今の自分を認めてあげてください
そして3つ目は
いまここにある自分を意識することなんです
過去や未来ではなく今ここに自分がいるんです
この3つのポイントというのは実は一つのことを言っています
丁寧に観察して自分のことを観察して来ずぷ
そして囚われているものに気がついたらそこから少し離れて見る
客観的になることなんです
そしてこのことは人生で1回やったからって何か意義があることではないんです
毎日の習慣にして初めて気が出てきます
私がマインドプロフィルスという名前で起業をしたのは
丁寧に気づいていくことで人はもっと健康になれると思ったからなんです
毎日どういう感覚があってどういう報道をしているかということに自分自身に気づく
ようになると
いろんなことが見えてくるんです例えばどんな食べ物を食べてどれくらいお腹いっぱい
になったら
調子がいいか
何時間ぐらいに持ったら次の日元気でいられるか
運動をしっかりした後は肌がすっきりしてストレスも取れていることにも気付くことも
あると思います
そういった一つ一つに日付くような習慣を作るんです
まず最初は傷っているんですけど酷いても自分が囚われているものから離れるって
なかなかできないんですね
例えは悪いものを食べてるって気づいてても食べてしまいことってあると思います
ただそれを毎日毎日築いていくと良いものと悪いものが出てきた時にこっちを食べた方
が体調がいいなーっていうことを自然に選べるようになってくるんです
おおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおお
ここにいる皆さんにも毎日ちょっとずつでもいいので自分を心静かに見つめる時間を
作っていただけたらと思っています
自分を心静かに見つめるいまここにある自分を見るっていうのはいつでもどこでもでき
ます
今からでもできるんです
例えば皆さんがしている呼吸ですね息が入って出て行く
風紀が入ると鼻なぁの花7を空気が通り抜けて感覚があると思いますそして動きがお腹
に入っていくとお腹が少し膨らみますね
そういったこと普段は認識しないと思うんですそれにあえて注目する時間をちょっと
だけでも作る
そしてそれを毎日続けるそれだけでも大丈夫なん
そうしたひと呼吸がきっかけになって皆さんが本当に大切にしたいこと一番やりたい
ことを見つけられることを祈っていますありがとうございました
[拍手]